هذا هو مشروع نظام الصرف الصحي للنفق العميق
أو dtss وهو جزء من
الخطة الرئيسية للمدينة تحت الأرض ، وقد تم
تصميم هذه الأنفاق خصيصًا للمساعدة في
الحفاظ على مورد مياه ثمين آخر
[موسيقى]
في الوقت الحالي نحن في أعماق الأرض على بعد حوالي
60 مترًا تحت الأرض نحن داخل
النفق  ما يميز
المشروع عن الآخر هو العمق الذي يزيد
عن 60 مترًا تحت الأرض بمجرد
اكتماله في عام 2026 ، يجب أن يحرر المشروع
ما يقرب من 150 هكتارًا من الأرض فوق
الأرض ،
شيء واحد يمكنك تعلمه عندما تقوم
بالبناء تحت الأرض هو بالطبع أن هناك
الكثير  عدم اليقين ولا يمكنك
أبدًا أن تكون متأكدًا مما ستواجهه ، ويجب على
جميع الأشخاص المشاركين في
جميع أصحاب المصلحة وصولاً إلى
مشغل آلة حفر الأنفاق أن
يكونوا على أهبة الاستعداد للاستجابة
للظروف المتغيرة بحيث يمكن أن يكون ذلك بالتأكيد
درسًا  التي يمكنك رفعها
لأعلى عندما تقوم بالبناء على
السطح ،
فهذا ليس الإجراء الجوفي الوحيد
هنا ، حيث تعمل سلطة الأراضي السنغافورية
على توأم رقمي منذ
عام 2014 ووسعت مؤخرًا هذا المشروع
ليشمل مساحة تحت الأرض
بينما يتم أيضًا استخدام خمسة كهوف ضخمة
لتخزين الهيدروكربونات السائلة
مثل النفط الخام الذي تديره شركة JTC وهي
وكالة حكومية مسؤولة عن
التنمية الصناعية ، تُعرف باسم
كهوف جورونج روك وتضم ما
يعادل 600 حمام سباحة بالحجم الأولمبي ،
كل ذلك لتحرير الأراضي الثمينة أعلاه